the man who kicks things off every
single day here on peacock nbc sports on
peacock
uh with his pro football talk live
program and pft pm
wraps up the day every single day the
hard-working mike florio how are you
mike florio rich doing great buddy how
are you i am doing well happy march sir
happy march this is where it's all going
to go down
um from free agency franchise tags
new television contracts it's a busy
march when you say
well you know it was a busy february and
there really wasn't much that was going
on i think the quarterbacks all got
together
and they parsed out the days that they
would dominate the news cycle and i
appreciate that
because once we got through the super
bowl it's like okay there's no scouting
combine we're not going to know the
salary cap teams aren't going to do
deals with their current players until
we know the cap
guys are going to get cut eventually but
not maybe all that many in february what
are we going to talk about
and from ben roethlisberger to russell
wilson deshaun watson and
whoever else happened to pop up i mean
it was great and and i really respect
the fact that they tried to spread it
out
because that really helped us get
through what would have been a slow
month
so let's talk about desean watson here
mike um
is the texans plan to just wait it out
and hope he comes around
and that um they they just hope he'll
come around before
they uh they're put in a position to
find him for not being in places where
he's
um contractually obligated to be is that
is that basically their plan
well whatever their actual plan is
they're doing a good job of creating the
impression
that their plan is we're not doing
anything
we hope that he will change his mind
we're not going to trade
this guy even though the fact that it's
gotten to this point
is already an indictment enough of the
texans you don't let it get to this
point
with the franchise quarterback with the
shortlist one of the top players in the
nfl
it's gotten to this point and i've seen
no reports from
anyone indicating that watson's resolve
is a ruse or contrived
or something that he'd abandon if push
comes to shove all signs are
he's made up his mind he's crossed the
rubicon and that's that
he's not going to play for the texans
ever again
and i don't know where the texans need
to to see that for themselves
but you know the longer you wait
the more you jeopardize your ability to
get maximum value and they can probably
push it up to the draft
to get maximum value but once the draft
picks are made for this year
i think it becomes harder and harder if
they have the realization that the guy
truly wants out he's not going to show
up
what are they going to do i mean if you
don't trade him he doesn't show up who's
your quarterback
for 20 21 and you've done nothing to get
value
for this guy so he sits out a year and
then you say a year from now geez well i
guess he was serious it just it makes no
sense to me if that's their plan well
here's
here's the deal from my perspective mike
and let's chop this up a little bit here
because deshaun watson asks for a trade
demand but he doesn't do it publicly we
find out subsequently
um when push comes to shove on the
subject matter in january
and then he meets with david culley
according to
a report um and we find out about that
subsequently we don't find that out the
day of he's not
he's not putting any pressure on the
texans in real time
he's kind of slow playing it himself and
usually standoffs as we've seen before
like this where i'm not coming in
i want to trade are based on finances
wanting to
renegotiate a contract earlier than then
convention
allows in the nfl or something like that
but he's already signed his monster deal
and if it was influence on hiring
somebody that will influence
his wins and losses that horse has
already left the barn as well
that leaves the subject matter of i
don't want to play for that guy
who signs my checks whose contract i did
accept a year ago
there's no way out of it that's that
that's my
spidey sense telling me this is over and
you might as well
strike it while the irons hot before
free agency
when other teams might be out of the
running because they go ahead and get
quarterback a b and c who clearly isn't
watson caliber your thoughts same page
100
and one of the reasons why watson hasn't
said anything
is he doesn't think he needs to say
anything there was an item in the
athletic about 10 days ago that
explained
he has a very stoic demeanor and he
prides himself on that and it was an
inspiration that he got from his mother
when she was fighting cancer
and he i believe doesn't think he should
have to
go public that he shouldn't have to put
direct pressure on the team and maybe
that's a card he's holding
for later if we get into the middle of
march
and if they continue to refuse and
maybe he's got to say something reveal
something disclose something sit down
for an interview
and be more candid in why he wants out
i think he wants to give it every fair
opportunity
to happen without him having to be
direct
and open and candid about what it is
that's bothering him and
you know if i'm the texans i see value
in getting this deal done before he
pulls the pin on the grenade
and tells the whole world all the things
he sees wrong with that organization
right now because that's not going to
help the organization going forward
mike florio pro football talk here on
the rich eisen show so we'll just wait
to see when
both the sides decide what a pressure
point is in order to make a move and
and see how it goes before the draft uh
you mentioned an athletic story about
watson the one about russell wilson
certainly caught my eye on thursday i
know it caught yours
as well do you think this could wind up
with wha
uh with russell wilson somewhere else
mike
i thought that it would happen next year
until i read that article and i think in
the aftermath of that article which
contains
surely items from the seahawks who have
said nothing publicly they've been the
mirror image
of the texan situation where in houston
it's texans talking
quarterback isn't in seattle it's
quarterback talking
team isn't but somebody from the team
shared some of that information with the
athletic
and rich when i got to the end of that
story and and i i
believe very strongly that anyone who
reads every word of one of these hashtag
long read stories should get a t-shirt
when i got to the end of it i said you
know if the seahawks don't view russell
wilson
the way that russell wilson views
russell wilson why not trade into a team
that does
because that team will offer something
that makes the seahawks safely
idiots think he's patrick mahomes so it
seems like it's inevitable and if it is
inevitable
you can either peel the band-aid off
slowly or just rip it off now and i
think if they
believe it's going to happen at some
point why not do it now
why not maximize your package and hope
that these four teams that were
identified by his agent last week
unprecedented i fell out of the chair
when the agent lists the four teams that
russell wilson would accept the trade to
play them against each other get your
best offer and move on i think there's
a lot of wisdom in doing that if you
think you're on a collision course
for a divorce with russell wilson anyway
yeah and it's interesting you say that
if you're if you're not viewing russell
wilson the way that he
wants to be viewed or you'd think most
other organizations would then why why
would you keep them why have that
why was there a set up at all where
where russell has be is told thanks but
no thanks
and he storms out of the room again you
know how stories get told sometimes
whether it's embellished or not or
who's who's the what's the reason why
somebody is
telling this story or not and where it
comes from is is of importance but
that one did surprise me it's like why
why wouldn't
russell wilson be allowed to do what he
really wants i understand that players
still need to be coached and coaches
still need to have
their influence on the way things are
run but how in the world is that not
how how has that happened where russell
is told yeah the last
seven turnovers are mostly your fault
get out of the room
well this is a pressure point i think
that the most obvious one
on the transformation we're seeing with
quarterbacks acquiring
more power more influence more control
and i think the tom brady
trek to tampa bay and what they were
able to do in his first year there
has thrown a wrench into a lot of these
quarterback relationships and whether
someone decides to take it public
like russell wilson or whether someone
is stewing privately
with a glass of scotch like aaron
rodgers and i suspect that he is
they see what brady did he picked his
team called his shot they've deferred to
him every step of the way
and they build the team around him and
russell wilson wants a team
where the offense will run through him
like it does with patrick mahomes
i think that's one of the reasons why
he's intrigued by the bears because it's
an andy reid
assistant who runs that same offense and
fine let me do what patrick mahomes does
in the same offense because
otherwise you look at the bears and say
russell why the hell do you want to play
for the bears that's the reason why
so i i think that
the brady dynamic is causing guys who
used to be petrified about becoming
villains in their own towns
russell wilson willing to put it out
there willing to go against the go hawks
grain
and let it be known that he wants
something different and you know what
most fans have reacted by saying you
know what the guy's got a point
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
um
what's going on with drew brees here we
are it's march 1st
and he's not retired and over the
weekend his uh
his hyper-energetic trainer todd durkin
uh
instagrams out videos of him
damn near uh shoving a uh a sled into uh
traffic i got a little scared for a
second but brees
thankfully stopped the sled filled with
weights and did turn around and went up
the hill with it
um and and durkin's message
definitely made it seem like uh this
isn't a wrap
for brees what's going on and the
narration
of that video sounded just a little
contrived if not rehearsed didn't it
i i don't know what's going on all i
know is this sean payton made the rounds
the week of the super bowl he was on pft
live on wednesday
of that week four weeks ago two days
from now he said we expect an
announcement within a week week and a
half and
everything has pointed to drew brees
retiring enrich
he reduces contract and slashes his
salary
from 25 million to the minimum of 1.075
with no quid pro quo
no signing bonus no money being moved
around he cut 24.925 million
in the stroke of a pen as part of an
effort to
minimize the cap hit while they carry
him on the roster until june second
processes retirement then
minimal capita i thought that was the
absolute
smoking gun that he's retiring and
he still hasn't retired and he's out
there pushing this sled around
and and and i think that some people
around the saints are starting to wonder
what the hell is going on here
and and mickey loomis the gm has been on
record saying he can play as long as he
wants which i don't think he means
but you have to say right it's just kind
of weird
at this point and every day that goes by
it's a little more conspicuous that drew
brees hasn't done what
what everyone thought he was going to do
and if you know look
for the past year the toothpaste has
been out of the tube that it's his last
year and drew drew's never said anything
to the contrary so
i i we just watch and we wait and uh
you know i don't know will i be stunned
if he decides to give it another go
i think this is another impact of tom
brady that the team that the saints
swept
in the regular season and beat 38 to 3
on the same field where the buccaneers
hoisted the lombardi trophy
they they catch the saints flat-footed
they beat the saints they run the table
they win the super bowl
how can drew brees not think at some
level i can go one more year
and we can try to get the lombardi and
if i don't do it
i'm going to be tormented by the fact
that i didn't give it a try for the rest
of my life yeah i mean look at tom
tom's out there age 43 and you know
throwing a pass to his son uh as his
beautiful
you know drew's beautiful wife brittany
looks on and we're all thinking well
that's it for drew
because brady just beat him in this in
the playoffs and he strolls off and he
wins the super bowl and if i'm breeze
part of me is thinking you know what
brady wouldn't have made the super bowl
if he had
19 of his ribs broken in the middle of
november you know like
you know like more broken ribs than ribs
exactly like anatomy
he did make me have to google how many
ribs does a human being have mike like i
actually didn't look at that
so i wouldn't blame him for he's sitting
there thinking let me just heal up
i can play till that end i can do the
same you know db9
system like i can do that too and i've
got michael thomas like
i can run this thing back i wouldn't
blame him for thinking that for a split
second
look at the pressure puts on the team
he's cut his salary by 24.925 million
dollars
he's given the team the ultimate i mean
we can praise tom brady all we want he's
never cut his salary 24.925 million in
one year and he's just coming back to
try to help the team win a championship
and hey i'll play half the time he told
us that
last year when the question was take
some hill and will he be back and
we talked to him about hypotheticals
with truly sharing the job and he said
he's got no problem as long as they win
he'll play as much or as little as they
want i mean if he walks through the door
and says
i'm here you want to use me use me if
you want to be a backup backup i'm here
i'm here and i'm not retiring if you
want to cut me cut me
but i'm here puts the saints in a very
awkward spot
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
the football yalta that is known as
rooney and roethlisberger went down what
what's the number
what's the number that these two guys
can agree on and get ben back out there
dealers had as of last week never said
anything to roethlisberger's camp
suggesting
that his new contract would be anything
other than
taking the 19 million he's due to make
this year turning it into
a signing bonus as much as they can you
still have to have a 1.075 million based
salary
but that's 18.925 it can be paid out in
one fell swoop
and you extend the contract multiple
years and you spread it out and you
reduce the cap number and you get in the
range of 25 million or something like
that
it would take a half hour to do it if
you really wanted to do it
with ben making 19 million the longer we
go
without that deal being done and art
rooney has set march 17 as a deadline
because that's the moment
the cap number for ben becomes 41.25
million
for the 2021 league year the longer we
we go the more i wonder are the steelers
gonna say to him hey
ben you said yourself i don't care how
much i get paid this year
well you shouldn't have said that
because we're going to take you up on it
right and then the question because
how much less will they try to get him
to take and and if brees comes out and
says i'm coming back and paying at one
by playing at 1.075 million
how do the steelers not start to think
man that sounds pretty good to us too
and the other side of this too rich
if ben roethlisberger will cut today
would someone offer him 19 million no
way to play for them this year so
you know i don't know how you go about
figuring out what the number is that
someone else would offer him
but whatever that number is that's the
most the steelers should want to pay him
last one for you mike uh why do we keep
hearing that uh
garoppolo isn't the apple of san
francisco's eye
at the end of the day and that there you
know that there's a wanderlust
potentially
for uh cousins and now bridgewater
or could be a home for watson which
would blow anything else out of the
water
what's going on well three things one 23
missed games in three regular seasons
for jimmy garoppolo and if i'm kyle
shanahan i'm still salty about
the tough guy maneuver on the sideline
where he dips his shoulder and tears his
acl and he's done for the year in 2018
in week three
second the game against the vikings
playoffs he threw three passes all of
them should have been intercepted by
eric kendricks he intercepted one of
them after the third one that wasn't
picked off
that's when they went into bob grizzy
mode for the rest of the postseason at
least until the super bowl he
he had everything but the bob grizzy
glasses remember how i used to wear the
glasses
on on his face with his helmet on in the
70s
uh through the through what eight passes
against the packers and so that's part
of it
and then finally 25 million just like
big ben who's going to pay if garoppolo
is available right now who's paying him
25 million this year
no buddy so if they could get cousins i
think they jump on it vikings aren't
letting them go vikings need to keep
cousins around
in order to help people remain employed
beyond 2021 in minnesota if they get to
the playoffs like they do every other
year
so i don't think he's going to be in the
mix but i think the 49ers are going to
look
for an upgrade somebody dollar for
dollar cheaper and i still believe
that garoppolo is going to be cut
because nobody's going to trade for that
contract and why would he reduce his
contract to facilitate a trade just say
cut me
and i'll go pick my next team with the
patriots be that team the patriots jump
all over him i think they could
potentially be that team but i'd have
the same concern that the 49ers had
looked the guy had a four game audition
in 2016
when tom brady was suspended he got hurt
in the second game that's my concern
and with the rules skewed in favor of
the quarterback to the most protected
players on the field other than the
punter and the kicker
how do you get injured as often as jimmy
garoppolo does and at a certain point
it's not just bad luck
it's something about you and i want a
quarterback who's going to show up and
play every
single week you need that if you want to
be a contender in the nfl mike you're
the man thanks for starting and ending
uh the nbc sports on peacock day every
day and look for my call let's do this
far more often anytime rich right back
at you that's it that's mike florio i
pro football talk
must follow hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here